PURNIMA KOCHIKAR: Good
morning, everybody.
How is everyone doing?
AUDIENCE: Good.
PURNIMA KOCHIKAR:
That is amazing,
because usually I have to tell
people, hello good morning.
This, I love the energy.
So thank you all for coming.
I feel totally
excited and humbled
to stand in front of a
room full of amazing women.
How often does it happen
in our industry, isn't it?
So before we get started, can we
give one more round of applause
for Women Techmakers,
the amazing organization
that has brought us together.
[APPLAUSE]
Thank you.
Today I want to talk
about building bridges.
Building bridges has shaped
me both professionally
and personally.
And I want to share
with you my journey
from a little
rural town in India
to where I stand here today.
If each one of us takes a
little moment to reflect,
I'm sure we can all find that
moment in time that shaped us.
Can you take a
moment to do that?
Sometime very early on that had
made a great impression on you.
For me, it was my
father walking back
from an academic conference
with a mechanical set.
My dad taught civil
engineering for 35 years,
and his specialty
was soil mechanics.
An expert in his field,
he was constantly
asked to come in to test the
viability of big structures
that were being built
all around us in India.
And so I grew up watching
him with huge plans,
looking at structures, mostly
bridges that looked big
and magnificent.
So holding this
mechanical set that I
could build my own bridges
seemed like the best gift
in the whole world.
Little did I
realize at that time
that the very act of a dad
giving a six-year-old daughter
a mechanical set was
actually remarkable,
not just for the
little town in India,
but anywhere in the world.
And just like that, that moment
told me that I could be anyone
I wanted to be.
I could build amazing
things, dream big dreams,
solve big problems.
Does that make sense?
But looking back, I realize
that it was not just
physical bridges that
shaped who I was.
My grandfather fought
for Indian independence.
He espoused the values of
human rights, gender equality,
and women's education
very, very strongly.
I never met him.
He passed away
before I was born.
But the home that I was
in embodied his values.
All around me, I saw
adults doing things
that needed to get
done, rather than
what was defined by gender.
My aunts fixed electrical
appliances, my dad sewed
buttons, and everybody played
a mean game of cricket.
Do you know what cricket is?
Yeah, and they were competitive.
No my aunts were like
not any pushovers.
They played a mean
game of cricket.
We had intense debates and
discussions on everything
from social topics to politics.
My parents also build bridges.
In our home were
people from all walks
of life, all faiths,
every economic strata,
coming in and participating.
I thought it was completely
normal for my very spiritual
mom to have a close
friend who was an atheist.
I thought it was completely
normal for my mom
to spend less time in
the kitchen and more time
reading and telling me
that I should do the same.
But all around me,
there were girl skills
that were being taught.
I thought it was completely
normal for my aunts
to pursue professional careers.
All around me, stereotypes
were being broken.
I saw adults taking
responsibility
for what needed to get
done, and more importantly,
is really exhibiting
true empathy.
So let's take a moment
to ask this question.
Whose world view are
we shaping around us?
Who's looking at us today?
Is it a little girl
or boy in your life
that is looking to
you for inspiration?
And are we exhibiting the
amazingness that's inside us,
breaking the stereotypes that
tells girls they cannot do
things, breaking the stereotypes
that tells boys that doing
certain things is girly.
What is our role?
Take a moment to think about
the people around you that
could do with a little bit of
inspiration, for whom you could
build a bridge from what is
being defined on the outside
to a better reality.
Now this is not all
about altruistic,
let's go save the world.
What I discovered is
that building bridges
and this bridging mindset gives
you negotiating superpowers.
How many of you
think that you're
better at negotiating
for others than yourself?
Yeah, me too, right?
Why is that?
There you are, passionately
negotiating for your team,
asking somebody to give
your employee a raise,
even maybe negotiating
for a sibling
to be able to go do something
but not for yourself.
Why is that?
And how can we tap
into our ability
to negotiate for
others for ourselves?
I discovered that
by just sheer chance
when I was a junior in college.
So when I was a
junior in college,
I was introduced to computers,
and the very act of coding
opened up my world.
I fell in love.
Yes, I'm a geek.
I totally fell in love with
the act of writing code,
so I was super
excited when I heard
that a local businessman
in my little town
was planning to start a
computer training institute.
I was convinced that
computing would open up
amazing opportunities
for the kids in my town,
that it would open up my town
to new and amazing businesses
or new ways of thinking about
how to solve local problems.
So convinced that I set up
time to go meet this person
and talk to him about using
computing to change the town,
to teach college students, to
create new jobs, et cetera.
And for whatever reason,
he said yeah, come join me.
I was so focused on telling
why it is good for others
that I never paused to think
about my lack of skills
or my lack of experience or
do I know all these things,
everything that holds
us back typically
when you are negotiating
for yourself.
So let me challenge you now.
What is the big
thing that you have
that you are trying
to go ask next week,
next month in your jobs?
Can we rephrase it?
Can we reframe it?
Can you reframe it in a way
that you are thinking about it
as a benefit to the business,
benefit to your team,
benefit to someone else.
Can you retell that story?
Something to think about.
Now fast forward.
A couple months after I
join, the senior person
on that institute left and I
found myself running the place.
I know.
You get thrown into
things, isn't it?
And so, all of a sudden, I was
thinking not just about coding
but about marketing
the courseware,
figuring out target segment,
understanding cash flows.
And suddenly, bridges
were being built
between tech and applications,
tech and business.
Figuring out how not only about
knowing what your product is
but how to make it
a feasible business.
It also introduced
me to my husband.
Vivek walked into the
institute to learn coding,
and we got into a very
big technical argument.
And then I learned that
within three months,
he was going to go to the
US for further studies.
And all of a sudden
just then and there,
I had to ask myself,
what do I do.
What do I do?
How does one compute this
risk-reward situation?
How does one do this?
How do you leave the comfort
of a little town where you are
sort of like a little big fish,
you're running this institute,
you're getting the strokes.
On a whim that this guy is
annoying and intriguing.
Yeah, what do you do?
What do you do?
I decided I'll use what
I learned in coding
and create a pilot.
So I applied for an exchange
program and came to the US
for a four-week exchange with
the Rotary International.
I said, OK let me go to the US.
Let's see what the
country is like.
Let's see what's going on.
Let's see if the boy still is
interesting, and then decide.
And so I landed in the United
States in the summer of '92.
It was beautiful
on the East Coast.
They say April showers give
May flowers or whatever?
It was abloom.
It was gorgeous.
Each week, I spent with
a different host family,
and their homes were gorgeous.
They had white picket fences.
They came in fancy
cars to pick me up.
I was like, wow, this is grand.
I could do this.
The boy was still
interesting, so I
said OK, let me figure
out how to come here.
Small problem.
I had no money, right?
So I met a couple of professors,
pitched them the fact
that I've been teaching
coding, maybe I
can get an assistantship,
and they said OK.
One of them thought he
could sort of give me
an assistantship.
So armed with a letter that
I would get an assistantship,
I go back to India, six
months of getting paperwork,
get to the consulate,
visa, et cetera.
I land in the Blizzard of '93.
No fancy cars to pick me up.
No sunshine and blooms.
I had never seen a tree with
no leaves that was not dead.
I had never seen snow.
And there I was
with this passion
that I was going to
learn more computing,
teach more computing.
I realized that my pilot
design was completely flawed.
Not only did I have no
skills to figure out
how to live in this country
that was gray and white,
I had no skills even
to take care of myself.
You have to understand.
I grew up in an extended family.
Everything was taken care of.
I didn't know how to cook.
I thought clothes got
clean by themselves.
I mean, bathrooms, ooh
do I have to clean that?
Right?
But I also realized
that I did not
have the skills to navigate.
I did not have the
skills to navigate.
I didn't know how to
ask, how to figure out.
And so I took the time to really
think about what are the places
that I really need to focus on.
And that experience I'm
distilling into three points.
One, every new world,
and this doesn't matter.
You don't have to go 10,000
miles to another country
to do this.
It could be just a new job.
Every new environment has
a way people communicate.
You need to learn that
underwritten rules
of communications.
Google is very data centric.
If you don't have data to
back it up, it doesn't work.
Make sense?
That's number one.
So I learned that how I was
saying and some of my jokes
were falling flat, because
nobody understood it.
So I joined Toastmasters.
I joined Toastmasters
and really worked
on being able to speak,
speak up, speak up
with very little notice.
Number two.
You really need a guide.
For me, thankfully, it was
the assistant of my professor
who was giving me
this assistanceship.
She coached me about how
to get basic stuff done.
And that was number two.
Find a guide.
Find somebody who
knows the situation.
And number three.
You need to have fun.
It's amazing how much
when we're overwhelmed
we put our heads down
thinking it's problem solving.
Find friends.
Find something that
gets your head up,
shows you all the wonderful
things that's inside of you.
These skills have
helped me make it
through countless transitions
from a student to a software
engineer, from a
software engineer
over to getting an
MBA, from an MBA
to going into
product management,
from product management
to where I am today.
Today, as Kurishma
pointed out, I
head a team that works with app
and game developers globally.
Building bridges across
technologies and cultures,
helping people achieve their
dreams on an amazing platform
called Android through
a distribution mechanism
called Google Play.
And every day, I'm amazed
by the immense creativity
and humbled by the
opportunity to tap into it.
So standing in
front of you, I am
as excited as when
I was a six-year-old
with the mechanical set.
Then, I was building
make-believe bridges,
but today, looking
at all of you,
I know we can build bridges
that will defy gravity,
that will defy rules, that will
defy things that people have
told us we cannot do.
So I have one challenge for you.
Before you leave here, I would
like you to take the time
to do three things.
One, write down
something that you want
to accomplish in the near term.
And figure out what bridges
you need to build to get there.
Do you know the rules
of communication?
Do you have a guide?
Do you have somebody
who can show you
a different perspective?
Number two.
Look around you and
find at least one person
you have never met and
truly get to know them
before you leave here today.
Most of our bridge
building is finding
the next node in your network.
And number three,
be a little bit more
aware about the
people around you
who are looking at
you for inspiration.
I know there are days, and
I go through this every day,
when you feel oh my
god, I'm overwhelmed.
There's so much to do.
But the very fact
that you are here,
you are light years ahead
of most people out there.
You're amazing.
You're a role model.
You're an inspiration.
You're a bridge to a lot of
people to a better tomorrow.
Thank you.
[APPLAUSE]